alors on tente de
de faire comprendre à nos obligations
générales que
justement pour une institution qui
peuvent dans le milieu du social que de
tels comportements vis-à-vis de ses
propres salariés ne sont plus
acceptables
d'ailleurs ces comportements ne l'ont
jamais été acceptable
ce qu'on cherche aujourd'hui
principalement ses incontesté
véritablement le
le plan de licenciement dans sa
globalité nous ne savons absolument pas
comment les catégories professionnelles
désigné dans le cadre de son plan de
licenciement ont été décidées puisqu'il
n'y a pas de plan de réorganisation de
l'institution s'inquiète beaucoup ce qui
nous inquiète beaucoup et c'est un souci
majeur en termes de déformation des
salariés il ya cette obligation
permanente d'informer les salariés en
particulier quand il s'agit quand on est
dans le cadre d'un redressement
judiciaire et là on est
on n'est pas informé du tout en tout cas
pas correctement sur la situation sur
les décisions qui sont réellement prises
ces licenciements prévus dans ce plan là
et les trois autres ce sont des départs
volontaires
ça c'est la première chose que je
souhaitais rectifié par ailleurs
l'administrateur judiciaire cliquards
ans de la loi a mis en place toutes les
mesures d'ordre juridique et pratique
pour que les choses se passent en
respectant la loi
donc je ne comprends pas très bien
aujourd'hui la réaction de ce syndicat
qui est chez nous minoritaire mais qui a
le doit laisser souffler ils ont le
droit d'être d'être embêtés hein parce
qu'ils ont des sentiments dont l'audois
de s'exprimer c'est ce qu'ils font et
nous nous sommes là en observation nous
attendons de voir comment les choses
vont évoluer dans les heures qui
viennent
mais pour l'instant toutes nos boutiques
sont ouvertes
le chrs fonctionnent nos usagers sont
pris en charge et c'est ce qui compte
pour le moment mais les salariés qui
sont aujourd'hui en débrayage c'est pas
une grève ils sont en débrayage ont le
droit de s'exprimer et ils l'expriment
comme le fond je n'ai pas d'opposition à
cela je dis simplement que je rappelle
que nous sommes dans le cadre d'un
redressement judiciaire et que par
conséquent nous avons des textes qui
nous conduisent et qui conduisent la
démarche à mettre en place et ce sont
ces textes et ces textes-là pardon qui
sont mises en oeuvre actuellement